GOOD AFTERNOON AND WELCOME BOTH
. FIVE ALL RIGHT AND WELCOME TO
TODAY'S HEARINGOF THE ASSEMBLY-
COMMITTEE ON THE RED AND TAX I
WANT TO REMIND EVERYBODY THAT
FOR THIS IN FUTURE HEARINGS
TESTIMONY MUST BE IN PERSON- WE
ARE ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY
THROUGH THE POSITION LETTER
PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. FOR THE BILLS BEING
TAKEN UP TODAY WE WILL TAKE NO
MORE THAN TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES
AND I THINK WE HAVE ONE JOHN
THAT WAS. USED. YEAH I THINK
IT'S- OKAY- THE FOR THE BILLS
THAT ARE BEING TAKEN UP TODAY WE
WILL HAVE NO MORE THAN TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND
TWO. RIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION THESE TWO WITNESSES
IN TOTAL HAVE OF FOUR MINUTES IF
THERE'S JUST ONE WITNESS- YOU
CAN OF THE FOUR MINUTES ALONE.
ALL SUBSEQUENT WITNESSES SHOULD
STATE THEIR NAME THEIR
ORGANIZATION THEIR POSITION ON
THE BILL ONLY FINALLY FILE ITEM
EIGHT AB TWENTY NINE THIRTY FOUR
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER WALDRON HAS
BEEN PULLED BY THE- AUTHOR AND
FOR THE FIRST TIME IT LOOKS LIKE
WE HAVE A QUORUM RIGHT AWAY SOME
IS HIGHLY PLEASED TO THE ROLL
CALL. IRWIN HERE. WHEN IT'S
GREAT. THERE GRAYSON LEVINE.
LIVING. MAYES MULLIN
PETRIE-NORRIS KIRK YEAH RIVAS
SERICA. WE HAVE ACCORDING. TO
DOING THIS FOR. SO. OKAY ALL
RIGHT SO WE ARE I UNDERSTAND
THIS GREAT- MOVING YOU OUT OF.
ORDER AND THIS IS- AB TWENTY
NINE FIFTY CORRECT. ITEM NUMBER
NINE. AND PLEASE BEGIN THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS AB TWENTY
NINE FIFTY WILL ESTABLISH
DEVELOP TAX CREDIT TO ENCOURAGE
PRIVATE INVESTMENT IN COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT CORPORATIONS. THREE
DEVELOPMENT CORPORATIONS ARE
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED NONPROFIT-
CAME BASED ORGANIZATIONS FOCUS
ON REVITALIZING AT THEIR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES THESE AREAS ARE MOST
OFTEN LOW INCOME UNDERSERVED
NEIGHBORHOODS AND HAVE
EXPERIENCE SIGNIFICANT
DISINVESTMENT. CDC'S PLAY A
VITAL ROLE IN BUILDING COMMUNITY
WEALTH AND INVESTMENT LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES BY DEVELOPING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND OFFERING
OTHER COMMUNITY HEALTH
INITIATIVES INCLUDING SOCIAL
SERVICES SUCH AS JOB TRAINING
AND HEALTH CARE SERVICES. THE
PROGRAM WILL OFFER A 50% TAX
CREDIT FOR GIFTS GRANTS FOR
CHARITABLE CONTRIBUTIONS OF ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS OR MORE
TO A CDC FOR PROJECTS THAT BUILD
COMMUNITY WEALTH AND RESPOND
ECONOMIC CRISES WHICH
REVERBERATES THROUGHOUT THESE
COMMUNITIES. UNDER THE BILL A
CDC BECOMES ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE
A CREDIT UPON THE ADOPTION OF A
COMMUNITY INVESTMENT PLAN WHICH
OUTLINES THE CURRENT AND
PROPOSED COMMUTER ELEMENT
PROGRAMS POLICIES AND
ACTIVITIES. IN MASSACHUSETTS A
SIMILAR PROGRAM GENERATED OVER
SIXTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS AND
PRIVATE DONATIONS FOR EFFORTS
AND SMALL BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT
HOUSING PRODUCTION JOB GROWTH
AND NEIGHBORHOOD REVITALIZATION
. AB TWENTY NINE FIFTY WILL HELP
ADDRESS THE CONTINUING
DISPLACEMENT OF RESIDENTS AND
SMALL BUSINESSES THE INCREASING
INCOME INEQUITY IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND THE STATE'S
HOUSING AVAILABILITY AND
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS. AMENDMENTS
TO THE BILL. I BELIEVE PROPOSED
BY THE COMMITTEE WILL DO THE
FOLLOWING AT A FIVE YEAR SUNSET
ADD THE REQUIRED SECTION FORTY
ONE LANGUAGE MOVE THE PROGRAM
OUT OF LOW INCOME HOUSING TAX
CREDIT PROGRAM OF TREASURE'S
OFFICE- ENSURE THAT RECIPIENTS
ARE NOT ABLE TO DOUBLE DIPPING%
CLAIM MULTIPLE TAX BENEFITS AND
CREDITS I BELIEVE THOSE WERE THE
SUGGESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE. IF
I'M INCORRECT THEIR MANAGER FEEL
FREE TO CORRECT ME- AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
TO. SORRY DID YOU MENTION THE
SUNSET. OKAY FIVE YEAR SUNSET
YES OKAY ALL RIGHT SO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. OF ARE YOU
ALONE. I IS IT JUST YOUR OTHER
TWO WITNESSES. OKAY SO YOU HAVE
FOUR MINUTES- GOOD MORNING
TROHMAN N. SO MANY WOMEN- I AM A
REPORT ABOUT A GUN EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNICATIVE ELEMENT
ASSOCIATION A MEMBERSHIP
ASSOCIATION OF TWO HUNDRED
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
FOCUSED ON ECONOMIC
REVITALIZATION UNDERSERVED URBAN
AND RURAL COMMUNITIES. ACOSTA
CALIFORNIA THIS ELIMINATION OF
REDEVELOPMENT TWENTY ELEVEN THE
STATE LEGISLATURE AND
INTERESTING HOLDERS HAVE BEEN
TRYING TO BRING BACK A
REPLACEMENT FUNDING MECHANISM
THEIR TARGET DOLLARS TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND SMALL
BUSINESS COMMITTEE SERVING
RETAIL AND LOW AND MODERATE
INCOME NEIGHBORHOODS PART OF THE
REASON READ LAWMAKERS HASN'T
BRING BACK REDEVELOPMENT IS
BECAUSE OF TH SIGNIFICANT COST
TO THIS DISEASE GENERAL FUND BUT
AT THE TIME OF INCREDIBLE
DISLOCATION AMONG SMALL
BUSINESSES AND HOUSING
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS OF HISTORIC
PROPORTIONS THE STATE'S LEFT
ONLY THE STATE IS THAT WAS THE
ONLY SOURCE OF FINANCIAL SUPPORT
TO ROLL EFFORTS BY CITIES AND
COUNTIES. TO RIGHT SIZE OUR
CMMUNITIES OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL LISTENING SESSIONS BUT
RESEARCHERS HAVE TRIED TO MEET
SOME OF THE GOALS OF THE FORMER
TO ALL PROGRAMS BRING
INTRODUCING BILLS THAT SOUGHT TO
INCREASE THE FUNDING SUPPLY FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
SUPPORTING THE CREATION OF NEW
JOBS BY PROVIDING TAX CREDITS.
IN TWENTY TWENTY TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA CAN ALLOCATE TASK IT
IS TO CREATE SPECIFIC COMMITTEE
DOME ATTACHED CREDIT PROGRAM
MODEL AFTER A VERY SUCCESSFUL
PROGRAM MASSACHUSETTS THIS
PROGRAM IS DESIGNED TO ENABLE
LOCAL RESIDENTS TO STAY COOL TO
WORK WITH AND THROUGH COMMUTER
ON THE CORPORATION'S COMMINGLED
FINANCES TUITIONS AND TO PARTNER
WITH NONPROFIT PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE ENTITIES TO IMPROVE
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES FOR LOW
AND MODERATE INCOME COMMUNITIES.
CDC'S COPPER SYSTEM THE ADOPTION
COMMITTEE INVESTMENT PLANS
RESPECTIVELY UNDERTAKEN
REDEVELOPMENT AND LENDING
PROGRAMS POLICIES AND ACTIVITIES
WHAT DOES THAT THE TRADERS
OFFICE AS A MINISTER IN THE
AGENCY FOR THIS AND THE CDC THE
COMMUTER ON TASKRABBIT AND HIS
RESPONSE FOR MANAGING THE
PROCESS BUT WHAT THE CREDITS ARE
ALLOCATED TO ELIGIBLE CDC'S
OTHER TWENTY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
COMMITTEE SERVICE DEVELOPMENT
DIVISION WILL BE RESPONSIBLE FOR
THIS SEPARATELY FOR CERTIFYING
YOU CAN REDEVELOPMENT
CORPORATIONS AND OTHER COMMITTED
WOMAN ORGANIZATIONS AS ELIGIBLE
ENTITIES. ELIGIBLE PRODUCTS WILL
INCLUDE AFFORDABLE HOUSING VERY
LOW LOW AND MODERATE INCOME
COMMITTEE FACILITIES CHILD
DEVELOPMENT COMMUNITY HEALTH
CARE ADMINISTRATIVE SUPPORT
MICRO SMALL BUSINESS LENDING
SMALL BUSINESS OF FOOD
INCUBATORS NEIGHBORHOOD RETAIL
DEVELOPMENT AND TO
GENTRIFICATION EFFORTS. CDC-
COMMERCIAL. A REALISTIC WAY. AND
JOB TRAINING SO IN IN. HOUSE L.
ORGANIZATION AND COMMITTED ONE
CORP COMMITTEE DOUBLE FINANCES.
COMMITTEE ACTION AGENCIES TWENTY
HOUSE OF ON CORPORATIONS SUCH AS
THE REAL ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATION AND THE RETURN BEEN
TRICKED ME DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATION. BASICALLY THE CITY
SEE I WAS A 50% TAX CREDIT FOR
GIFTS GRANTS ARE JOURNAL
CONTRIBUTIONS OF ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND MORE WILL FEEL IN THE
WORK OF MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED
CDCS AND COMMITTEE ACTION
AGENCIES AND ONE HUNDRED
SIGNIFIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
AWARDS ARE BASED ON THE QUALITY
OF IT UP TO SEE A P. AS
DESCRIBED BENEFIT TO LOW AND
MODERATE INCOME AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. AS THE CUSTOM ALTEZ
COULD PROGRAMS IT WOULD BE OVER
FIVE YEARS AND THEN SUNSET
UNLESS WE KNEW BY THE
LEGISLATURE. AN ADDITIONAL TOTAL
COSTS OF THE PROGRAM ORTEGA'S
SPINACH- BEING PROPOSAL BE
MODEST TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWO TO TWENTY
THREE. PORTAL WAS SET UP WOULD
OCCUR IN TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND
HOPEFULLY TEST CRICKET BE
AVAILABLE IN TWENTY TWENTY THREE
. THANK EVERY TIME I GET UP TO
SPEED TODAY. ALL RIGHT TO DO WE
HAVE ANY OF OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. ANY QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS ASSEMBLY MEMBER COURT
PALM GREAT BILL HAVE YOU BEEN
ABLE TO GET THE MONEY- NEEDED
FOR THIS IN THE BUDGET. I THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY APPRECIATE THE
COMPLIMENT ON THE BILL AND-
WE'RE STILL IN NEGOTIATIONS AND
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE BUDGET
CHAIR AND RESPECTIVE- BODIES
ABOUT THAT CERTAINLY WOULD LOVE
TO SEE THIS GOING FOR BUT AT
THIS POINT CAN'T SAY THAT WE
HAVE IT- FOR MARRIAGE. WELL LET
ME KNOW IF YOU NEED HELP. THANK
YOU SIR. DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER-
QUESTIONS OF YOU KNOW WE'VE BEEN
TRYING FOR THE LAST NUMBER OF
YEARS TO TRY TO GET SOME FORM OF
REDEVELOPMENT IN AND IT HAS NOT
BEEN SUCCESSFUL I'D I OFTEN.
LOOK AT MY DAYS ON THE CITY
COUNCIL AND HOW MUCH- WE WERE
ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH ESPECIALLY IN
THE AREA OF REDEVELOPMENT THAT
BUILDING LOW INCOME HOUSING SO-
HOPEFULLY- YOU HAVE I MEAN WITH
THIS WITH THE WAY THIS BILL IS
SET UP. THAT YOU WILL BE LOOKING
AT HOW IN A MAIS ABUSES WHICH
SORT OF ENDED UP SPELLING THE
END OF A REDEVELOPMENT BACK IN I
THINK WAS TWENTY TWELVE OR
THIRTEEN SO- APPRECIATE YOU
WORKING ON THIS ISSUE I THINK
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT. AND THE
WITH THAT I WOULD LIKE TO PROP
UP. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
PRECIADO THE SPECIAL
ACCOMMODATION- IN IN THE
PRESENTATION- BEING EARLY HERE
THIS AFTERNOON- AND THANK YOU
FOR THOSE COMMENTS I WAS
ACTUALLY WORKING- IN THIS
INSTITUTION IS LEGISLATIVE STAFF
PERSON WHEN WE I DID
REDEVELOPMENT AND- WE'RE HAPPY
TO BE WORKING FOR. A LEGISLATOR
WHO FOUGHT HARD AGAINST IT BUT
UNFORTUNATELY WENT THROUGH AND I
THINK THERE ARE MANY REGRETS-
TODAY AND HOPEFULLY AT SOME
POINT WE CAN GET SOMETHING
ESTABLISH APPRECIATE YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN THE COMMITTEES AND
THANK YOU FOR THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THE EXCELLENT
SUGGESTIONS ON THE BILL. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR. I GUESS A
LOT OF RESPECT FAST DRIVER WERE
TESTIMONY ON THE RIGHT FOR TEST
FINALLY SO YOU CAN COME BACK AND
ASK FOR AN IPHONE THANK YOU SO
MUCH ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. NOW WE HAVE OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BENEFITS AND THIS IS THE-
LAST REGULAR ORDER OF BUSINESS
SO THE COMMITTEE KNOWS THIS.
THIS DOES REQUIRE A VOTE.
WELCOME MR BENNETT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS NOTED-
IN THE ANALYSIS ON PAGE THREE AB
TWENTY FOUR FIFTY THREE SIMPLY
PROVIDES A VOTERS OF INTER
COUNTY THE ABILITY TO RAISE
HEIR TAXES IF THEY CHOOSE- THE
TRANSACTION AND USE TAX TO
PROVIDE FOR MORE INFRASTRUCTURE
FUNDING. OF THE BILL DOES NOT
INCREASE THE TAX ITSELF- THAT'S
THE DISCUSSION CONTINUES IN MAY
WITH THE VOTERS IT SIMPLY ALLOWS
THE LOCAL AGENCIES TO BE ABLE TO
PUT THIS TAX- IN FRONT OF THE
VOTER SHOULD THEY CHOOSE TO DO
THAT. UNDER EXISTING LAW CITIES
AND COUNTIES ARE AUTHORIZED TO
IMPOSE TRANSITION. TRANSACTIONS
IN USED TAXES IN QUARTER CENT
INCREMENTS AS LONG AS THE
COMBINED RATE IN THE COUNTY DOES
NOT EXCEED 2% VENTURA COUNTY HIT
THAT CAP ONE ONE CITY RECENTLY
PASSED A SALES TAX INCREASE. ON
A BI PARTISAN VOTE THE VENTURA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS-
PASSED A RESOLUTION REQUESTING
OUR LEGISLATURE SUBSISTENCE AND
RAISING THE COUNTY'S CAP. IN
THIS BIPARTISAN- WHAT HAS
HAPPENED IN OTHER COUNTIES ALSO-
IN THE LEGISLATURE'S TAKEN
SIMILAR. ACTION TO ASSIST THOSE
LOCALITIES- WITH ME TODAY IS
JAMES THURBER WATCHER- FROM THE
STATE COUNCIL LABORS AND ANDY
FIELDS FROM REBUILD SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA- I REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE. A GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIRS MEMBERS MANY CENTER
FIELDS AND- I'M HERE
REPRESENTING- THE VENTURA COUNTY
FIRST COMMITTEE FUNDING
INNOVATIVE RELIABLE AND SAFE
TRANSPORTATION WE'RE GRASSROOTS
COALITION THAT INCLUDES
ORGANIZED LABOR SMALL LOCAL
BUSINESS ECONOMIC GROUPS
ENVIRONMENTALISTS ENGINEERS AND
LOCAL ELECTED OFFICIALS. SINCE
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN OVER
VARIOUS ITERATIONS WE'VE
SUPPORTED INCREASE IN FUNDING
FOR OUR CRUMBLING INFRASTRUCTURE
SYSTEM IN OUR OVERBURDENED
TRANSIT AGENCIES. I WOULD LOVE
TO SPEAK MORE ON THE ECONOMIC
BENEFIT THE PASSING SUCH A
MEASURE WOULD MAKE TO THE
WORKING MEN AND WOMEN OF THE
COUNTY OR TO THE ENVIRONMENTAL
BENEFIT OF HAVING FEWER CARS
IDLING IN TRAFFIC OR TO THE
PERSONAL BENEFITS THE VENTURA
COUNTY COMMUNITY. AND GETTING
WORKING PARENTS HOME FASTER
STUDENTS WALKING OR BIKING TO
SCHOOL WITH INCREASED SAFETY OR
RECREATION ENTHUSIASTS WILL
BENEFIT FROM THE CONNECTED
COUNTY WIDE BIKE TRAILS BUT
THAT'S NOT WHY I'M HERE I'M ONLY
HERE TO ASK YOU TO ALLOW US TO
PRESENT TO THE VOTERS OF INTER
COUNTY THE CHOICE. OF WHETHER
THEY'RE WILLING TO IMPOSE A TAX
ON THEMSELVES IN EXCHANGE FOR A
WHOLESALE TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM
AND SAFETY IMPROVEMENT. YOU ARE
ALL FAMILIAR WITH THE
PREDICAMENT IN THE COUNTY WHEN
ONE JURISDICTION REACHES A 2%
LOCAL SALES TAX CAP THERE IS
MORE THERE IS NO MORE ABILITY TO
COLLECTFUNDING FROM. FOR OTHER
AREAS OF IMPORTANCE. WE'RE NOT
ASKING YOU TO RAISE TAXES JUST
AS WE DID NOT ASK THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS TO RAISE TAXES WHEN
THEY VOTED TO SUPPORT AB TWENTY
FOUR FIFTY THREE. WHICH THEY DID
NOT ONLY WITH CUSTOMER WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. WE'RE SIMPLY
ASKING YOU TODAY TO AUTHORIZE
THE CITIZENS TO VOTE ON THIS ONE
VERY SPECIFIC ISSUE WITH A VERY
SPECIFIC CAP RELIEF NUMBER OF
ONE HALF OF ONE PERCENT. TO BE
USED SOLELY FOR THE PURPOSES SET
FORTH AND TRANSPORTATION
EXPENDITURE PLAN. AS YOU WELL
KNOW THIS CAP RELIEF HAS BEEN
DONE A NUMBER OF TIMES IN THE
PAST ALWAYS WITH THE AGREEMENT
THAT IF THE COUNTY SUPPORTS THE
ITEM. IT CAN BE LEFT THE COUNTY
TO IMPLEMENT IT. THAT'S
CERTAINLY THE CASE HERE OUR
COMMITTEE HAS PERFORMED PUBLIC
OPINION RESEARCH TWICE OVER THE
LAST TWELVE MONTHS. IN HIS
RECENTLY AS LAST MONTH WHEN NEWS
OF SOARING GAS PRICES AND
RAMPANT INFLATION REDDIT'S APEX.
THE PEOPLE OF INTER COUNTY
OVERWHELMINGLY SUPPORT MOVING
FORWARD WITH THE MEANS TO FIX
OUR TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM.
BECAUSE THE PHONE ON THE MOBILE
THE- FOR THE ME TOO LINE IS AN
OPTION TODAY I'D LIKE TO
REITERATE THE AMOUNT OF
PROMINENT SUPPORT WE HAVE FOR AB
TWENTY FOUR FIFTY THREE. TO NAME
A FEW THIS INCLUDES. ORGANISE IT
ORGANIZED LABOR SUCH AS THE
LABORS OPERATING ENGINEERS
CARPENTERS. THE REBUILD SO CAL
PARTNERSHIP AND TRANSPORTATION
CALIFORNIA. AS WELL AS LOCAL
SMALL BUSINESSES SUCH AS
MEISSNER FILTRATION. TORO
CONSTRUCTION AND THEN S.
ENGINEERING BOYS CONSTRUCTION.
W. S. P. THE TWENTY TWENTY
NETWORK. THE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AS WELL AS A NUMBER
OF LOCAL ELECTED OFFICIALS. AND
I HAVE TO ASK YOU TO WRAP IT UP.
THANK YOU WE ARE G. A. VOTE.
PERFECT TIMING AFTERNOON THAT
ENSURING MEMBERS JAMES DIRECTOR
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
COUNCIL LABORS HAPPY TO BE HERE
IN SUPPORT AND HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE ROUGHLY SIXTY THOUSAND MEN
AND WOMEN THAT WE REPRESENT
STATEWIDE WHO WORK IN THE HEAVY
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY I LIKE TO
THINK THE AUTHOR FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP AND HIS STAFF- FOR
THIS FOR THE SHIPPING
INTRODUCING THIS VERY CRITICAL.
BILL AB TWENTY FOUR THIRTY THREE
SIMPLY PROVIDES THE BORDERS OF
INTER COUNTY WITH THE ABILITY.
TO IMPOSE A TRANSPORTATION SALES
TAX TO PROVIDE FOR MORE
INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING. TO MEET
VENTURA COUNTY'S CRITICAL
MOBILITY NEEDS. IT IS IMPORTANT
TO NOTE THAT THIS BILL DOES NOT
INCREASE. THE TAX ITSELF THAT
DISCUSSION WILL REMAIN WITH THE
VOTERS. EVEN IF THE VOTERS DO
IMPOSE CHOOSE TO OPPOSE THE
TRANSPORTATION SALES TAX THE
COUNTY WILL JOIN MORE THAN
TWENTY OTHER SELF HELP COUNTIES.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WILL
BENEFIT FROM ADDITIONAL STATE
FUNDING THAT IS EXPRESSLY
PROVIDED FOR THE STATE'S LOCAL
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM.
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS
SUPPORTED BY THESE PROGRAMS
CREATE AND SUPPORT THOUSANDS OF
QUALITY MIDDLE CLASS
CONSTRUCTION CAREERS AND JOBS.
FOR ABOUT BUILDING TRADES
WORKERS AND PUBLIC EMPLOYEES WHO
WORK WITH STATE AND LOCAL
TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES. THEY
GET OUR MEMBERS WHO ARE
OVERWHELMINGLY MEN AND WOMEN OF
COLOR- THE REAL PATHWAYS TO
MIDDLE CLASS TO MIDDLE CLASS AND
TO HOMEOWNERSHIP. IN ADDITION
SUPPORTING LOCAL ROAD REPAIR IN
TRANSIT AND PROVEN PROJECTS WILL
INCREASE ROADWAY SAFETY FOR BOTH
DRIVERS. AND PEDESTRIANS AND A
DEEP DECREASES VEHICLE
MAINTENANCE COSTS FOR MOTORISTS.
SOME EXAMPLES OF THE PROJECT IS
MEASURE WOULD SUPPORT INCLUDE
PAVING AND RESURFACING ROADS.
INVESTING IN SIDEWALKS AND
BICYCLE LANES AND REVAMPING AND
REPAVING LOCAL BRIDGES AND
OVERPASSES AMONG OTHERS. THE
LOCAL PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM
CARRIES WILL BECOME ELIGIBLE TO
RECEIVE TRACK TRANSPORTATION
DOLLARS TO MATCH LOCAL SOURCES
OF VOTER APPROVED FUNDING THANK
YOU FOR TIME. THANK YOU ANY
OTHER WITNESSES AS PART. ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. OF DO
YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. SECOND ALL RIGHT AND
COMMENT FROM DR CORK YES SO I'VE
WORKED ON BILLS LIKE THIS AND
GOVERNOR NEWSOM. DOESN'T LIKE TO
INCREASE THE ACTUAL LIMIT BUT
HE'S WORKED ON WORKAROUNDS WITH
ME FOR EXAMPLE SAYING WELL WE
CAN INCREASE WE CAN LET THIS
CITY HAVE THIS TAX QUESTION
BECAUSE WE WON'T POWER SAY THE
BAR TAX. BECAUSE THAT'S YOU KNOW
SEPARATE. SO HE'S FOUND
WORKAROUNDS BUT I THOUGHT YOU
KNOW THE SOONER YOU CAN GET THAT
WORKAROUND AGREEMENT WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. THE BETTER
OFF YOU'LL BE. YEAH I THOUGHT-
AND DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER.
COMMENTS RIGHT AND I DO HAVE A
QUICK COMMENT SURE AND- SO I
THINK AND I TRIED I DON'T KNOW I
SHOULDN'T PUT WORDS INTO THE
GOVERNOR'S MATH BUT I KNOW THAT
THE REASON THAT I HAVE
HISTORICALLY- OPPOSE BILLS LIKE
THIS. TIME AND OPPOSE RAISING
THE STATE'S 2% CAP IS BECAUSE
SALES AND USE TAXES ARE I MEAN
IT'S THE MOST REGRESSIVE WAY FOR
US TO RAISE REVENUES I'M- SO.
GET COMMENTS OR YOU KNOW
PERSPECTIVE ON THAT. FROM THE
SENATE SPECIALIZED THEY
CERTAINLY DO YOU KNOW IF YOU
LOOK AT- MANY OF THE OTHER FIRST
WORLD COUNTRIES IN EUROPE THAT
WE COMPETE WITH THEY HAVE VALUE
ADDED TAXES AND- IT IS THE WAY
THE WAY THAT THEY HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO SERVE- THOSE VERY SAME LOW
INCOME PEOPLE- SO WELL AND SO I
THINK WHEN YOU HAVE THE RIGHT
INVESTMENTS AND I DON'T THINK
ANYBODY WOULD SUGGEST THAT. THE
EUROPE IS- MORE ENGAGED IN AND
THAT SORT OF NOT TAKING CARE OF
THE LOW INCOME PEOPLE THAT
YOU'RE REFERRING TO WHAT'S
REGRESSIVE TAXES- THANKS I
CERTAINLY THINK THEY FOUND A WAY
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
INVESTMENTS ARE REALLY
APPROPRIATE INVESTMENTS AND THIS
IS AS APPROPRIATE ON THE BEST
MAN AS YOU CAN GET. IT HELPS
EVERYBODY IN THE COMMUNITY-
BECAUSE WE ARE ON A COUNTY CLOSE
TO LOS ANGELES THAT DOES IS NOT
A SELF HELP COUNTY AND I WOULD
OFFER. TO DO TWO THINGS ONE.
WHEN GOVERNMENT WORKS BEST WHEN
IT HELPS PEOPLE HELP THEMSELVES
THIS IS GOING TO LET PEOPLE. AS
GONNA BURKE IS GONNA LET PEOPLE
DECIDE IF THEY WANT TO HELP
THEMSELVES AND THEN ALL WE'RE
DOING IS JUST TRYING TO SAY
OKAY. IF YOU'RE WILLING TO DO IT
THAT I LOVE THESE OPPORTUNITIES-
SAME THINGS HAPPENED WHEN WE HAD
A- A LOCAL TAX TO BUY A SCHOOL.
FOR A LOCAL LOW INCOME
COMMUNITY. AND IT WAS A THAT WAS
A TAX TO PURCHASE SCHOOL THEY
VOTED FOR IT AND WE CAN HELP
THEM BECAUSE THEY VOTED TO TAX
THEMSELVES. THAT'S THE SAME
THING THAT I THINK IS HAPPENING
HERE. THE OTHER THING THAT I
JUST WHILE I HAVE THE FLOOR HERE
FOR YOU IF YOU DON'T MIND ME
POINTING OUT IS THAT IS THAT.
THERE ARE VERY FEW THINGS THAT
WE GET BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON
ANYMORE IN THIS COUNTRY. AND WE
COME TO YOU WITH BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT FROM THE VENTURA COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS- AND IF I
THINK PART OF WHY WE HAVE THAT
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IS BECAUSE
WE'RE HELPING PEOPLE HELP
THEMSELVES WERE SAYING TO THEM.
IF YOU WANT TO DO IT IF YOU WANT
TO DO THE WORK ROLL UP YOUR
SLEEVES TAX YOURSELF AND DO ALL
THAT MAKE SURE THE MONEY IS
SPENT WILL. WILL HELP YOU BY
GETTING OUT OF THE WAY THEY HAVE
A THEY HAVE A TECHNICAL PROBLEM
NUMBER TRAVIS ALL THE TECHNICAL
PROBLEMS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
QUESTION I APPRECIATE. SO LIKE I
JUST WANT TO FOLLOW UP ON THAT
AND REPEAT AGAIN FOR I THINK THE
FIFTH TIME THAT THIS IS NOT
RAISING TAXES THIS IS GIVING THE
ABILITY OF INTER COUNTY TO. OF
TO RAISE TAXES AND THIS IS WE
HAVE KIND OF A UNIQUE SITUATION.
THERE ARE PROBABLY. FOUR OR FIVE
CITIES THAT HAVE NEVER RAISE
THEIR TAX SO THEY ARE AT THE
VERY LOWEST LEVEL IN THE STATE.
SO THERE'S IT JUST HAPPENS THAT
ONE CITY IS THE ONE THAT'S
THAT'S AT THE LIMIT THAT IS KIND
OF CAUSING THAT ISSUE. AND WE
ARE- UNFORTUNATELY LOSING OUT ON
A LOT OF MATCHING FUNDS IN
VENTURA COUNTY SO. WE WILL SEE
IF THE VOTERS DECIDE THIS TIME
THAT'S THE OR I SHOULD SAY IN
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR DECIDE THAT
THEY ARE. WILLING TO INCREASE
THE TAXES ON THEMSELVES BUT I
THINK THE ARGUMENT WILL BE THAT
WE'RE LOSING OUT ON A LOT OF
PROJECT FUNDING BECAUSE WE ARE
NOT A SELF HELP COUNTY SO. AND
WE'LL SEE THAT IF WE CAN HAVE
THE SUPPORT OF THIS COMMITTEE
AND I. RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE. ALL RIGHT AND- SO
YOU'VE AGREED TO ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS PROVIDING THAT ANY
DISTRICT TAXES IMPOSED UNDER
THIS TAX WILL NOT BE CONSIDERED
FOR THE PURPOSES OF THE COMBINED
2% LIMITATION CORRECT. CORRECT
ALL RIGHT. OF WITH THAT WE HAD
A- MOTION BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LEVINE AND A SECOND PIE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK AND THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE FLOOR MS HIGHLAND PLACE TO
CALL THE ROLL. ON AB TWENTY FOUR
FIFTY THREE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS CEMENTED. IRWIN HI- WHEN I
WHEN. WHEN NO GRAY. GREAT I
GRAYSON GRAYSON I LIVING LEVINE
I MAYES MULLIN. MULLIN AYE
MULLIN AYE PETRIE-NORRIS EACH
UNIVERSITY WILL KIRK OUR- WAY
RIVAS I RIVAS ICE SEYARTO.
CYRANO. IT SEVENTY THREE THE
BILL'S THE BILL ITSELF THANK YOU
MISTER BENNETT. ALRIGHT I THINK
WE HAVE- WE ARE ON IS MISTER NO
MISTER GIPSON THIS INDUSTRY. IF
BUT IF YOU WANT- MR O. OKAY
BIGGER ON THE- YEAH WHAT'S UP TO
YOU OKAY SO WHY DO WE HAVE A
MISTER CHOICE BEEN SITTING HERE
FOR AWHILE. OKAY YOU KNOW ALL
ABOUT. OKAY AND THEN IF YOU
WANNA TALK TALK CHART. THE LAST
WILL HOPEFULLY BE DONE BY THE-
GOOD AFTERNOON DOCTOR CHOI.
THANK YOU IT'S A- MINE NOT A WIN
AND THE MEMBERS. I'M PLEASED TO
PRESENT THE IN THE. EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY NINE. IT IS TO FOLLOW. AB
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY NINE OR TO
PROVIDE A TAX DEDUCTION FOR
TEACHERS SO WHO SPEND THEIR OWN
MONEY FOR INSTRUCTIONAL
MATERIALS AND THE CLASSROOM
SUPPLIES. 94% OF A PUBLIC SCHOOL
TEACHERS TO SPEND ABOUT THE FOUR
HUNDRED EIGHTY DOLLARS SUPPORT
YEAR ON CLASSROOM SUPPLIES. WHY
ARE SOME SUPPLIES ARE ARE
REIMBURSED UP BY THE- SCORES SO
MANY DEDICATED TEACHERS SO SHE
THE NEEDS IN THEIR CLASSROOM AND
THE FIELD OF COMPOUND TO HELP
THEIR STUDENTS- BY PURCHASING
ADDITIONAL SUPPLIES OF SUCH AS A
WORK BOOKS. OR THE BOOKS AND US
ARE UPDATED MATERIALS SO WITH
THE HELP ONE PERSON OR FUNDS.
NEW TEACHERS SISTER AT THE
LOWEST END OF A SALARY SCALES
WHILE ALSO STRUGGLING TO REPAY
COLLEGE LOANS. AS THE AS WE OR
NORMAL CALIFORNIA IS- IN THE
MIDDLE OF WHAT TO CHAU SHORTAGE
. I WOULD TEACHERS- NEED THIS
ASSISTANCE ASTERN BEN STUDENTS
BENEFIT FROM THE GENEROSITY OF
THE- TEACHERS SAID AND THAT THIS
TAX DEDUCTION MAY ALLOW TEACHERS
TO SPEND EVEN MORE FOR THE-
CLASSROOM TO ULTIMATELY BENEFIT
THAT THE- STUDENTS. MANY LEAD
CUSTOMER- MIGHT LEAD. A TEST OF
TESTIMONY MISTER RYAN REYNOLDS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
RIPPLE- PROVINCE SCHOOL
ORGANIZATIONS SO WERE NOT ABLE
TO COME TO THE US A TOTAL OF TWO
SACRAMENTO TODAY BUT THERE HAS
TO SUBMITTED A LETTER EXPRESSING
HIS TO SUPPORT THAT AND- WHY
HIS- NOT THIS MEASURE IS A VERY
IMPORTANT FOR OUR- EDUCATORS.
THIS BILL RECOGNIZES OF
DEDICATED TEACHERS AND THE HOUSE
OF TO DEFRAY THE COST OF FOR
THE- PURCHASES. SO FOR THE-
CLASSROOMS. WE DON'T HAVE ONE IN
PRESENTS. OR ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN THE ROOM IN SUPPORT
- THIS IT IS POPULATION. ALSO
ALL RIGHT YEAH BOB. SO MY
CONCERN HERE IS THAT HALF THE
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA DON'T PAY
TOP STATE TAXES AT ALL. ARE THEY
PAID THE FEDERAL TAX. AND MOST
PEOPLE PAY A FEW PERCENT 234%
BUT IF YOU. IF YOU'RE A TEACHER
AND YOUR HUSBAND MAKES A MILLION
DOLLARS YEAR YOU'RE PAYING 13%
TO JUST GET A LOT MORE BACK IF
YOU'RE WEALTHY AND YET YOU'RE
MORE ABLE TO PAY IT IF YOU'RE
WEALTHY- I OULD PREFER TAX
CREDIT RATHER THAN A TAX
DEDUCTION. THANK YOU. THE
ELEVEN- A LOT MORE ATTRACTIVE-
BUT LAST YEAR WE TRIED THE TAX
CREDIT AND- THIS- COMMITTEE- AND
THEN ALSO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE HAD THE CONCERN- TO
MANY PEOPLE ASK FOR FULL.
VARIOUS TO THINGS FALL
PREDECESSORS SO THIS YEAR- HE-
TRY I AM TRYING TO MAKE IT TAX
DEDUCTION INTO SOMETHING WOULD
BE MUCH BETTER THAN NOTHING. SO
WHAT NOW WE CAN WORK ON THAT-
BUT THE- INITIAL STEP IS SO
RECOGNIZING THEIR SACRIFICES AND
DEDICATION FOR ALLOWING. THE A
TAX DEDUCTION IN CALIFORNIA.
RIGHT THANK YOU FOR TRYING TO
TAKE CARE OF OUR TEACHERS
BECAUSE THEY DO THAT COME HOME A
WHOLE FAMILY OF TEACHERS AND WE
USED TO HAVE THIS PROBLEM ALL
THE TIME APPARENTLY BE SPENDING
MONEY ON ON ALL THESE EXTRA
SUPPLIES ALL THIS REALLY DOES IS
IT'S BRING CALIFORNIA COMPLIANCE
WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
ALREADY DOES IN IN THEIR TAX
CODE YES SO WE WOULD BE
CONFORMING WHICH IS ACTUALLY A
GOOD THING EXACTLY- ESPECIALLY
FOR TAX PREPARERS EXACTLY I
APPRECIATE YOUR BILL THANK THANK
YOU FOR POINTING THAT OUT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER START. SOMEWHERE
TELL ANY OTHER. OKAY I WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE. I RESPECT B. F.
WE I'VE WORKED OKAY WELL THANK
YOU FOR THAT PRESENTATION AND
LET'S MOVE ON TO YOUR NEXT BILL-
AB EIGHTEEN NINETY ONE- YES
EIGHTY NINE OKAY THIS IS A
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY NINE. EIGHTEEN
NINETY. SO STE EIGHTEEN NINETY
ONE OKAY I WILL PRESENT TO A
JUDGE WILL NOT VOTE ON THIS ONE
NOPE THERE'S NO VOTE NOT LIKE WE
ONLY VOTED ON WORK WILL BE
VOTING LATER I SEE NO SAYS SITE
AYE SO FOR THIS TESTIMONY ONLY.
OKAY MY NEXT BUT IT IS SO AB
EIGHTEEN NINETY ONE- EVERY YEAR
AT THE ISSUE OF HOMELESSNESS AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS A PRIORITY
FOR CALIFORNIA. YET THAT WE FIND
OURSELVES SO IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE UNPRECEDENTED DAHLE HOUSING
CRISIS ACOSTA BY SEVERE LACK OF
A NEW HOUSING CONSTRUCTION- FOUR
METERS TO LOW INCOME RESIDENTS
AB EIGHTEEN NINETY ONE SURFSIDE
SL ONE OF MANY TOUR SO TO HELP
ADDRESS OUR OUR STATE SO HOUSING
CRISIS. THIS BILL PROVIDES UP AN
INCOME TAX CREDIT FOR THIS ONE
ARE FOR PROPERTY OWNERS WHO RENT
EUNICE OF BELOW MARKET RATE TO
TEMAS SO RECEIVING HOUSING
SERVICES. SO WHAT ASSISTANCE. BY
PROVIDE OF THIS- AND- IT IS MY
HOPE THAT THE LANDLORD SO OR OR
FOR ROLL RENT TO THOSE SO WHO
STRUGGLE TO FIND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. AND THE NEED THE
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT. I WOULD LIKE
TO THANK- MISTER DAVID KNIGHT
THE WHOLE SUPPRESSANT HERE- WITH
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY ACTION
PARTNERSHIP ASSOCIATION OF FOR
JOINING ME TODAY A TO ASSISTANCE
TO A TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. GOOD AFTERNOON AND AS
A ASSEMBLY MEMBER DR CHOI HAD
SAID I'M DAVID KNIGHT EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COMMITTEE ACTION PARTNERSHIP
ASSOCIATION. WE ARE NONPROFIT
MEMBERSHIP ORGANIZATION BASED IN
SACRAMENTO THAT IS COMPRISED OF
SIXTY COMMITTEE ACTION AGENCIES
COMMITTEE SERVICE BLOCK GRANT
ELIGIBLE AGENCIES. THROUGHOUT
ALL FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA NO EACH AGENT EACH
AGENCY WE REPRESENT CREATES
LOCALLY DEVELOP SOLUTIONS AND
OPPORTUNITIES AS WELL AS THE
MINISTERS CRITICAL FUNDING. AND
SERVICES TO HELP ECONOMICALLY
DISADVANTAGED CALIFORNIANS IN
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES TO
MAINTAIN STABILITY INCREASED
OPPORTUNITY TO DO TO ACHIEVE
SELF RELIANCE. NOW BEHALF OF OUR
BOARD OF DIRECTORS AND OUR
AGENCIES I'M HERE TO LEND THEIR
SUPPORT FOR A BI EIGHTEEN NINETY
ONE AUTHORIZED BY THE STATE OF
THE STATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER STEVEN
CHOI. NOW CALCUTTA MEMBERS FOCUS
HEAVILY ON CREATING OPPORTUNITY
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS TO HAVE THE
ABILITY TO PROSPER IN THEIR OWN
COMMUNITIES ASSEMBLY MEMBER
STORY MEASURES A MAJOR STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION FOR EACH
COMMUNITY WE SERVE. OUR STATE
HAS BEEN FOCUSING A LOT ON
HOUSING WE OFTEN HEAR THE WORDS
HOUSING HOMELESS OR RENT ORDERED
FROM A- COLLECTIVE FISHER'S
DALY. WE HAVE TO MENTION
HOMELESS IS A PROBLEM IN OUR
STATE YET IN ACTUALITY IT IS
CURRENTLY THE SOLUTION TO
MULTIPLE OTHER PROBLEMS ALL OF
YOU HERE TODAY ARE AWARE OF SOME
THE ACTUAL PROBLEMS THAT LEAD TO
THESE CURRENT ON WANTED
SOLUTIONS. WE CAN'T TACKLE ALL
THE ISSUES IN EVERY BILL BUT AB
IN EIGHTEEN NINETY ONE
DEMONSTRATES A STRONG SOLUTION
TOWARDS OVERCOMING ONE MAJOR
GLARING ACTUAL PROBLEM IN OUR
STATE. THE CONTINUED LACK OF
ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE RENTAL
HOUSING. NUMBER BY PROVIDING A
TAX CREDIT TO A PROPERTY OWNER
FOR LEASING WATER MORE
RESIDENTIAL UNITS BELOW MARKET
VALUE TO AN INDIVIDUAL FAMILY OR
HOUSEHOLD RECEIVING HOUSING
SERVICES OR ASSISTANCE FROM A
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION. AB
EIGHTEEN NINETY ONE IS A
REALISTIC THOUGHTFUL SOLUTION TO
CREATING THE MUCH NEEDED ACCESS
THIS ONGOING LACK OF ACCESS TO
SOMETHING SAME ARE AGENCIES
EVERY SINGLE DAY YOU NEED TO DO
TWO THINGS TO BE SUCCESSFUL AT
CREATING OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
FAMILIES WE SERVE. GREAT FUNDING
GREAT ACCESS ALL THE FUNDING
OVER TO THE COUNTRY CAN CAN
OFFER DOESN'T CREATE ACCESS. FOR
COMMUNITIES WITHOUT ACCESS TO
USE IT. HE WILL YEARS TO THE ME
TO GO OF ECHO HOUSING STATE
THEY'VE BEEN SET FORTH BUT- ARE
STRONG. TODAY ACQUIRING THE LAND
IS VALUABLE BUILDING AND YOU CAN
IT'S TIME CONSUMING BUT THE
CURRENT RENTAL HOUSING STOCK.
WHICH COULD GIVE ACCESS TO A
FAMILY RIGHT ON THE VERGE OF
TYPING IN HOMELESS TODAY. IS A
REAL PRACTICAL SOLUTION FOR
TODAY WHILE ALSO ENSURING LONG
TERM SUCCESS FOR THE FUTURE.
SETTING A PRACTICE OF CREATING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR MULTI LEVELS
OF INCOME TO RESIDE TOGETHER
WITHIN COMMUNITY. WITH EXECS IN
HOUSING RATHER THAN SIMPLY
RELYING ON YOU BILLS. IS A SOUND
POLICY THAT WILL ASSIST OUR
AGENCIES MEET THEIR MISSION.
HOWEVER WE NEED TO INCENTIVIZE
PROPERTY OWNERS WHO WOULD LIKE
TO HELP IN DEVELOPING OUR
COMMUNITIES TOGETHER. A FATHER
DOLLAR TAX CREDIT FOR QUALIFYING
UNIT. NOT TO EXCEED FIVE
THOUSAND PER YEAR IS AN AMAZING
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION. I
HOPE YOU WILL NOT ONLY SUPPORT
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS CHOICE
LEGISLATION BUT MAKE IT- AND
RENTAL AND OTHER RENTAL TAXES IN
OF THE BUDGET PRIORITIES. THIS
IS SMART PUBLIC POLICY NOW IS
THE TIME TO USE. I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONTINUED SERVICE TO OUR
STATE TO OUR FAMILIES. AND ALLOW
ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
TODAY ON BEHALF OF CAL CAMPUS
BOARD OF DIRECTORS MEMBERSHIP.
THANK YOU MANAGER. THANK YOU-
MISTER I KNOW WHETHER. WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION I ASSUME- DO WE
HAVE ANYBODY IN THE ROOM AND
SUPPORT. ANYBODY ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS. I SAID THANKS FOR
BRINGING THIS MEASURE FORWARD.
THE DEFINITION OF- FAIR MARKET
VERSES UNDER MARKET IS
INHERENTLY SUBJECTIVE SO HOW. IN
THE MOMENT MORE LOOKING AT
FISCAL POLICY WE CANNOT LOOK AT
THINGS THAT ARE SUBJECT OF IT
HAS TO BE OBJECTIVE IT HAS TO BE
YOU KNOW HARD NUMBERS SO HOW IN
THE WORLD WOULD YOU POSSIBLY
CALCULATE THAT AND HOW WITH THE
STATE POSSIBLY BE ABLE TO
IMPLEMENT THIS. CAN I ANSWER I
THINK THAT'S A VERY VERY SIMPLE-
QUESTION ANY- RENTAL UNIT OWNERS
THE GOAL BY- PREVAILING. ARE
RENTAL OF PRICE AND OBVIOUSLY
THEY WANNA RENT THEY ARE RENTAL
YOU NEED AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE
RATHER THAN WAITING BECAUSE OF
TIME IS S. AS- OF WHAT THEY'RE
MAKING MONEY- SO THEY WILL DO
THEIR MARKET RESEARCH AND WHAT
THE PRICE WOULD BE RIGHT UP AND
ASKING PRICE AT THAT THE SO
MARKET PRICE. AND THE IF THE
SELF FOR EXAMPLE TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS OF. AND THE RENT IT FOR
AFFORDABLE LEVEL WAR NONPROFIT
THOUGH MORE PEOPLE WITH THE
HOUSING ASSISTANCE SO LET'S SAY
FOR TWELVE HUNDRED DOLLARS TO
FIFTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS. THAT IS
A DISCOUNT PRICES. RIGHT IT'S
MISTER KNIGHT RIGHT SO- UP I'M
NOT SURE WHICH ONE OF YOU CAN
ANSWER THE QUESTION BUT- FORT IF
WE'RE TRYING TO BE EFFICIENT
WITH THE GOVERNMENT DOLLARS.
DOES IT REALLY MAKE SENSE TO
START A- BRAND NEW- CREDIT
PROGRAM AS OPPOSED TO SUPPORTING
A ESTABLISH PROGRAM OR MORE
ROBUSTLY SUPPORTING ONE OF THE
ESTABLISH PROGRAMS. I THINK FOR
US IN OUR AGENCIES IN THE
FAMILIES WE SERVE. IT DEPENDS ON
SPECIFICALLY WHAT PROGRAM WE MAY
BE DISCUSSING ONE OF THE ISSUES
THAT WE CONSTANTLY SEE IN OUR IN
OUR NEIGHBORHOODS AND
COMMUNITIES. BECAUSE WE HAVE
UNITS THAT ARE BUILT AND THEY'RE
BUILT WITH INCENTIVIZE PROGRAMS
RIGHT FOR LOW INCOME FAMILIES.
IN THOSE UNITS SIT VACANT
BECAUSE THERE'S NO DIRECT
CORRELATION THERE'S NO. THERE'S
NO ABILITY TO TRACK WHETHER AN
ACTUAL FAMILIES IN THOSE UNITS
AND I THINK WITH THIS TAX CREDIT
IN THE WAY IT'S WRITTEN IS
ALLOWS US TO SAY. WE ENSURE THAT
THERE'S A FAMILY IN THAT PLACE
BECAUSE THEY'RE GONNA HAVE TO
SHOW THAT THAT FAMILIES IN THAT
IN THAT LOCATION. AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT THAT WE SEE ON
THE GROUND EVERY DAY AND THAT'S
WHAT THE BIGGEST CONCERNS WE
HAVE. THAT'S NOT THE CASE WITH
OTHER TAX YOU'RE YOU'RE SAYING
IF THE- IF DEVELOPERS ARE USING
OTHER TYPES OF. TAX CREDITS THAN
THE UNITS ARE OFTEN SITTING
EMPTY. CORRECT WE SEE THAT QUITE
A BIT IS THE ISSUE IS THAT.
UNITS WILL END UP BEING LONG
TERM INDIANS NOT ACCESSIBLE- AND
THEY SHOULD BE HAVE ACCESS TO
LOW INCOME PEOPLE THAT'S JUST
SOMETHING WE SEE ON A COST
BASIS. AS A CONCERN FOR A LOT OF
FAMILIES THAT WE SERVE- ARE NOT
NECESSARILY ALLOWED TO COME INTO
THOSE UNITS FOR DIFFERENT
REASONS YOU KNOW MAYBE A LOT OF
THE FAMILIES WE SERVE HAVE HAVE
MULTI. GENERATIONAL FAMILIES IN
ONE PLACE THEY DON'T GET ACCESS
TO THOSE THINGS AND THAT'S VERY
VERY DIFFICULT FOR US TO
CONTINUE TO DO OUR WORK. OKAY
ALL RIGHT- WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE DR CHOI. OKAY IF YOU DO
VOTE TODAY I WOULD LOVE TO GET
YOU OFF- SUPPORT IF NOT THEN THE
WHEN YOU COME TO THAT POINT TO
ASK FOR YOUR RIFLE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH TALKED CHOI FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT NEXT UP WE HAVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FONG. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
FONG YOU CAN MAKE PROCEED
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. I THANK
YOU CHAIR MEMBERS. STILL
RECOVERING FROM THE COVERED
PANDEMIC NONPROFITS AND
EMPLOYERS- STILL CANNOT ABSORB
SIGNIFICANT EXTRA COSTS SITTING
ON A SIGNIFICANT BUDGET SURPLUS
AT THE MOMENT THE STATE CAN
INSURE THAT NONPROFITS AND
EMPLOYERS ARE SUPPORTED WHILE
EMPLOYEES ARE PROVIDED SICK
LEAVE TO CARE FOR THEMSELVES OR
FAMILY MEMBERS THIS BILL AB
NINETEEN TWENTY PROVIDES SMALL
BUSINESSES AND NONPROFITS WITH
NEEDED TAX RELIEF TO OFFSET THE
COST. OF THE SUPPLEMENTAL PAID
SICK LEAVE UNFUNDED MANDATE THAT
WAS PASSED BY THIS LEGISLATURE
THESE ARE HOMELESS SHELTERS
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS
CHILD CENTERS- A LOCAL ANIMAL
SHELTERS IN A BEEN A BUSINESSES
AND ALL YOU NEED BUSINESSES IN
OUR COMMUNITIES THESE ARE THE
SAME RESILIENT BUSINESSES THAT
HAVE FACED CONSTANT UNCERTAINTY
WHILE MANAGING TO RETAIN THEIR
EMPLOYEES WITHOUT THIS TAX
RELIEF THOSE JOBS AND BUSINESSES
ARE PUT AT RISK. A HOMELESS
SHELTER IN MY DISTRICT SAID
THERE ANNUAL BUDGET BEFORE THE
SIGNING OF S. B. ONE ONE FOUR
AND BECAUSE SB ONE ONE FOUR WAS
RETROACTIVE TO THE START OF THE
YEAR. THEY FACE IMMEDIATE ARE
NOT ENORMOUS AND ON BUDGET COSTS
THIS TAX CREDIT IS MODELED AFTER
THE FEDERAL TAX CREDITS X. AS X.
ASSESSABLE LAST YEAR TO OFFSET A
SUPPLEMENTAL PAID SICK LEAVE
HOWEVER THOSE CREDITS HAVE
EXPIRED AND EMPLOYERS ARE LEFT
TO REBUILD DURING A PERIOD OF
HIGH INFLATION BALL TILE LABOR
MARKETS AND MORE STATE MANDATES.
ALSO THIS TAX CREDIT IS
SPECIFICALLY AND INTENTIONALLY
TARGETED AT SMALL BUSINESSES AND
NONPROFITS PROP AND NONPROFITS
THAT ARE PILLARS OF OUR
COMMUNITIES AND ARE IN MOST NEED
OF FINANCIAL RELIEF AND FOR
THOSE REASONS I WOULD ASK FOR
AYE BUT WHEN IT'S- WHEN THE TIME
COMES AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU MISTER
FIND YOU HAVE ANY REDNESS IS NOT
TIME AT IT ANY WITNESSES IN THE
ROOM AND SUPPORT. ANY WITNESSES
IN THE ROOM IN OPPOSITION
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. YOU KNOW IT IT
SEEMS TO ME THAT IF WE COULD.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO RETURN
TAXES BECAUSE WE'VE GONE OVER
THE GALLON BUT- IF THIS ARE BILL
COULD USE DAM LIMIT MONEY TO PAY
PEOPLE BACK I DON'T KNOW WHAT
THE BEST WAY TO DO THAT IS IT
COULD BE JUST TO. IN L.
APPROXIMATE. I DON'T KNOW IF
THEY WANT TO GO THROUGH
EVERYBODY CLAIMING THIS IS THE
ABOUT BUT GIVING MONEY BACK TO
OF THE CORPORATIONS YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT I IN A WAY THAT
SORT OF- WOULD COMPENSATE THEM
FOR TYPICAL AMOUNTS OF SICK
LEAVE THAT THEY MIGHT HAVE GIVEN
OUT DURING THAT TIME PERIOD
MAYBE CERTAIN AMOUNT PER
EMPLOYEE. WHATEVER I THINK THIS
WOULD BE FEASIBLE IF WE COULD.
FIND IT THAT WAY THROUGH THE
GALA BUT ACCESS. OF DO YOU OR
DOES THE COMMITTEE CHAIRED TO
SEE ANYONE HAVE AN IDEA WHETHER
OR NOT THAT COULD BE DONE. IT IS
MY UNDERSTANDING AND THE
COMMITTEE- CAN CORRECT ME BUT-
THAT BEGAN IF ANYBODY'S ABOVE
AGAIN LIMIT WOULD HAVE THE BROAD
BASED ACTUALLY IF THIS IS A VERY
TARGETED TAX CREDIT- AT THAT IS
TO SPEAK TO FILL A SPECIFIC GAP
THAT WAS CREATED- WENDY
ADDITIONAL SICK PAY LEAVE A
PROPOSAL WAS PUT INTO PLACE. BUT
WHEN THE ORIGINAL SICK PAY LEAVE
PROPOSAL WAS PASSED- AT THE BAD
DURING THE PANDEMIC- THERE WAS A
FEDERAL TAX CREDIT IN PLACE THAT
ALLOWED SMALL BUSINESSES AND
NONPROFITS- TO TAKE IT TO OFFSET
THOSE COSTS. WHEN THE- WHEN SB
WOMAN FOR WAS A WAS SIGNED INTO
LAW THAT FEDERAL TAX RATE HAD
EXPIRED. SO NOW THAT THE SMALL
BUSINESSES AND NONPROFITS IN OUR
COMMUNITY HAVE TO ABSORB AT A
COST BECAUSE IT WAS RETROACTIVE
TO THE BEGINNING OF THE YEAR BUT
I WOULD DEFER TO THE- TO THE
COMMITTEE CONSULTED OR THE
CHAIR- IF THERE'S ANY ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION I GOT INCORRECT OR
THAT WAS. THAT WAS WRONG.
CONSULTANTS LIKE TO ADD ANYTHING. I'M CERTAINLY NOT AN EXPERT ON
THE GANN LIMIT BUT I MEAN IF YOU
LOOK AT THE LANGUAGE OF ARTICLE
THIRTEEN BE IT DOES SPEAK TO
RETURNING MONEY TO REVISION OF
TAX RATES OR FEE SCHEDULES AND
NOT TAX CREDITS TO PARTICULAR
INDIVIDUALS. OKAY ALL RIGHT
WELL- IF THERE'S A WAY I'LL
CERTAINLY SUPPORT. I'VE BRIGITTE
THAT HAS A BUNCH OF THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE WE ARE STRUGGLING WITH
AGAIN LIMIT AND WE'RE WAITING
FOR THE MAY REVISION SO- WE ARE
CERTAINLY- EAGER- IF THERE
ISN'T. A WAY TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL TAX RELIEF- THROUGH
DO IT IS A REVENUES THERE ARE
GOING TO MATERIALIZE OR HAVE
MATERIALIZED. WE CERTAINLY ARE
WELCOME THAT CONVERSATION. A
JUST A COMMENT REALLY SO THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS MEASURE
FORWARD- YEAH I THINK. THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED FIVE. SB
NINETEEN TWENTY. BECAUSE HE
THOUGHT THERE WAS A PUBLIC
HEALTH IMPERATIVE I. TO DO SO
AND- YOU KNOW I'M OF THE VIEW I
KNOW THAT YOU ARE OF THE VIEW
THAT. I IT'S THE ROLE OF
GOVERNMENT. TO MEET THAT COST.
NOT THE ROLE OF OUR SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS- SO. WOULD ALSO
BE VERY HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS
AND- I'M DO YOU HOPE THAT THERE
IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO EXPLORE
PROPS AND- CREATIVE. APPROACHES
IN TERMS OF ENSURING THAT WE CAN
ACTUALLY. GET SOMETHING LIKE
THAT UNDER THE PROJECT THAT
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THAT
FORWARD THINKING. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VALLADARES. YOU
ARE UP.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS IT'S MY PLEASURE TO
PRESENT AB TWO EIGHT ZERO THREE
WHICH WILL HELP INCENTIVIZE
EMPLOYERS TO PROVIDE THEIR
EMPLOYEES WITH CHILDCARE
SERVICES AS A FORMER EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF A NONPROFIT
PRESCHOOL AND CHILD CARE CENTER
WHERE WE SERVE CHILDREN FROM
EIGHTEEN MONTHS TO FIVE YEARS
NOT OF SCHOOL AGE I KNOW FIRST
HAND HOW ESSENTIAL CHILD CARE IS
TO A CHILD'S DEVELOPMENT. AND TO
PARENTS PARTICIPATION IN THE
WORKFORCE THE COVER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC HAS EXACERBATED
WORRISOME TRENDS IN THE CHILD
CARE INDUSTRY OUR WORK FORCES
WHEN DEALING CHILD CARE OPENINGS
ARE VANISHING ANDSOME PARENTS
HAVE BEEN UNABLE TO RETURN TO
THE WORK FORCE AS A RESULT.
THOSE WHO ARE LUCKY ENOUGH TO
FIND IN A FOURTEEN OPENING ARE
FORCED TO PAY PRETTY MUCH A
FORTUNE CHILD CARE COSTS ARE
SKYROCKETING CALIFORNIA AND
WORKING PARENTS AND CARE GIVERS
ARE MAKING UNIMAGINABLE
SACRIFICES TO FOOT THE BILL FOR
MANY FAMILIES IN CALIFORNIA
CHILD CARE REPRESENTS THEIR
LARGEST MONTHLY EXPENSE ONE
STUDY HAD CALIFORNIA'S AVERAGE
ANNUAL PRICE OF CHILDCARE TAGGED
AT ELEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS FOUR
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE DOLLARS
ELEVEN THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FIVE DOLLARS. THIS IS
JUST TOO HIGH THIS BILL REALLY
AIMS TO HELP THE MISSING MIDDLE
CALIFORNIA HAS DONE AN AMAZING
JOB ALLOCATING CHILD CARE SLOTS
FOR THOSE AND LOW INCOME OR
SUFFERING FROM POVERTY- HOWEVER
THE MIDDLE CLASS MAKES TOO MUCH
MONEY TO QUALIFY FOR CHILD CARE
SERVICES BY THE STATE AND NOT
ENOUGH MONEY TO ACTUALLY PAY FOR
CHILD CARE. IN ORDER TO FULLY
PARTICIPATE IN THE WORK FORCE WE
MILLIONS OF PARENTS NEED MORE
ACCESS TO CHILD CARE OPTIONS AND
MORE SUPPORT THAT'S WHY I'VE
INTRODUCED AB TWENTY EIGHT OH
THREE WHICH OFFERS CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYERS A TAX CREDIT FOR
DEPENDENT CARE SUPPORT AS A
STANDARD BENEFIT FOR THEIR
EMPLOYEES AND DOING SO THE BILL
UP CLOSE CARE GIVING SUPPORT
GAS BY INCENTIVIZING. EMPLOYERS
ESPECIALLY SMALL AND MICRO SIZE
BUSINESSES TO OFFER THEIR
EMPLOYEES ASSISTANCE WITH CHILD
CARE COSTS. EIGHTEEN OTHER
STATES HAVE EMPLOYER PROVIDED
CHILD CARE TAX CREDITS BY
PASSING AB TWENTY EIGHT OH THREE
THE LEGISLATURE WILL NOT ONLY
HELP CONNECT PARENTS WITH CHILD
CARE. BUT WILL PROVIDE OUR
BUSINESS IS A POWERFUL TOOL TO
BE MORE COMPETITIVE AND
RECRUITING TALENTED WORKERS THIS
BILL ACKNOWLEDGES A DIVERSE
CHILD CARE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIANS. AND WILL HELP
ENSURE EMPLOYERS ARE ABLE TO
PROVIDE THEIR EMPLOYEES WITH
MORE AFFORDABLE AND ACCESSIBLE
CARE OPTIONS FOR THEIR CHILDREN
pVOTED ON TODAY I HOPE THAT WE
CAN BRING IT TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR A VOTE A VOTE AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT MOVING FORWARD. WITH ME
TODAY TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY EIGHT OH THREE AS
BRIAN JAMALI WITH CARE .COM.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER GOOD
AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TEST. FOR YOU TODAY. MY NAME'S
BRIAN SMELLING THE HEAD OF
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS AND PUBLIC%
POLICY FOR CARE DOT COM- WE'RE A
LEADING PLATFORM FOR FINDING AND
MANAGING HIGH QUALITY FAMILY
CARE AND THAT'S EVERYTHING FROM
CHILD CARE TO SENIOR CARE TO
OTHER TYPES OF HOME CARE IN
ASSISTING THE PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES WITHIN THE HOME AS
WELL- AND TETIFYING TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY OH THREE-
THIS BILL. AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
VOTERS MENTIONED TO CREATE A
MODERNIZED EMPLOYER PROVIDED
CHILD CARE TAX CREDIT FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT WOULD
BENEFIT WORKING FAMILIES. I IN
THE OVERALL CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY
BY REDUCING THE COST OF CARE FOR
WORKING FAMILIES INCREASING
ACCESS. TO CARE BY PROVIDING
MORE FLEXIBLE AN EQUITABLE
OPTIONS FOR FAMILIES. I
INCREASING LABOR FORCE
PARTICIPATION ESPECIALLY AMONG
WOMEN. THE CONCEPT IS NOT NEW
TAX POLICY DISCUSSIONS CURRENTLY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
APPROXIMATELY EIGHTEEN STATES
OFFER- EMPLOYER PROVIDED CHILD
CARE TAX CREDIT. CALIFORNIA
CURRENTLY DOES NOT OFFER A STATE
LEVEL COMPLEMENT- AB TWENTY
EIGHT OH THREE WOULD NOT ONLY
ADD CALIFORNIA TO THAT LIST OF
STATES THAT OFFER THIS CREDIT.
BUT WOULD SERVE AS A NEW
NATIONAL MODEL. FOR MODERNIZE
CREDIT BY INCORPORATING SPECIFIC
CREDIT DESIGN AND POLICY CHANGES
SUGGESTED IN A RECENT GAO
REPORT- EXAMINE WAYS TO IMPROVE
THE FEDERAL LEVEL CREDIT- INTO
OF THOSE WAYS- THAT WE'RE
PROPOSING TO MODERNIZE THIS IN
ADDITION TO- THE TRADITIONAL
CONCEPTS INCLUDED IN. OTHER
STATE CREDITS AND FEDERAL
CREDITS IS TO. EXPAND THE
DEFINITION OF QUALIFIED CARE
EXPENDITURES TO INCLUDE IN HOME
CARE AND BACK UP CARE. OPTIONS
SO THAT THE FULL PORTFOLIO OF
CARE OPTIONS ARE AVAILABLE TO
WORKING FAMILIES. AND SECONDLY
PROVIDING MORE GENEROUS CREDIT
TO SMALL BUSINESSES IN
CALIFORNIA. IN RECOGNITION OF
THE CRITICAL ROLE THAT THEY PLAY
IN CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VALLADARES-
MENTIONS OF THE CARE GAPS THAT
EXIST SO I WON'T BE REDUNDANT
AND REPEATING THOSE POINTS. BUT
WE'RE REALLY TARGETING- THE POOL
OF FOLKS KIND OF IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE CARE SPECTRUM THAT REALLY
HAVE NO TOOLS IN THEIR TOOL BOX
AGAIN THEY CAN'T ACCESS SUBSIDY
PROGRAMS. AND THEY CERTAINLY
DON'T MAKE ENOUGH MONEY TO PAY A
100% OUT OF POCKET. AND TAX
POLICY- REALLY IS THE ONLY TOOL
IN THEIR TOOLBOX THAT'S A BUILT
ON WHETHER IT'S CHILD DEPENDENT
CARE TAX CREDITS IF THEY'RE
LUCKY ENOUGH TO. BE OFFERED A
DEPENDENT CARE ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM THROUGH THEIR EMPLOYER.
OR HAVE ASSISTANCE AND SUBSIDIES
THROUGH EMPLOYER PROVIDED CHILD
CARE CREDIT LIKE THE ONE WE'RE
PROPOSING HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
HOWEVER ONLY ABOUT 11% OF
WORKERS NATIONALLY HAVE ACCESS
TO EMPLOYER PROVIDED CHILD CARE.
SO THAT GAP JUST CONTINUES TO
STAY STAGNANT ALONG THAT
SPECTRUM AND WE'RE REALLY TRYING
TO BE THOUGHTFUL AND STRATEGIC
IN CLOSING THAT GAP. CHUKKER
ISN'T JUST EXPENSIVE FOR
CALIFORNIA WORKING FAMILIES FOR
SOME IT IS EVEN AVAILABLE-
CALIFORNIA IS A STATE 60% OF THE
POPULATION LIVE IN CHILD CARE
DESERTS. AND THAT'S ESSENTIALLY
CENSUS TRACT WHICH IS NOT HAVE
ENOUGH. SUPPLY TO MEET THE
DEMAND FOR CHILDCARE SLOTS. IN
IN THOSE PARTICULAR TRACKS- IN
THE DESERT'S ASSOCIATED WITH
YOUR MOTHERS IN THE WORKFORCE
AND US THEIR SECRET DRIVER OF
THE OVERALL LABOR SHORTAGE. IN
CALIFORNIA. AND WITH HYBRID
MODELS WORK LIKELY HERE TO STAY
IN THE RISE OF THE DECENTRALIZED
WORKFORCES ACROSS INDUSTRIES.
COMPANIES ARE LOOKING TO PROVIDE
EMPLOYEES ARE CERTAINLY LOOKING
FOR. MORE FLEXIBLE CARE OPTIONS.
WITH THREE DAYS IN THE OFFICE I
TWO DAYS AT HOME FOR TWO DAYS IN
THE OFFICE AND THREE DAYS AT
HOME. FAMILIES ARE JUST NOT
TAKING THEIR CHILDREN INTO THEIR
OFFICE BUILDING AND DROPPING
THEM OFF AT THE CENTER AND THE
LOBBY OR DOWN THE STREET. THEIR
HOME A FEW DAYS THERE ARE
WORKING FOR A COUPLE DAYS AND
THEY'RE JUST LOOKING FOR MORE
FLEXIBILITY MORE SEEING THOSE
TRENDS CERTAINLY- ON OUR
PLATFORMS AS IS I THINK ALL- ALL
ENTITIES THAT ENGAGE IN
PROVIDING CHILDCARE SUPPORT. TO
FAMILIES. SO AB TWENTY OF THREE
WE'LL CERTAINLY ADDRESS THAT
ISSUE AS WELL. OUR I THINK IT'S
FAIR TO SAY THAT WE ALL KNOW THE
NATIONAL CAREGIVING CRISIS IS
NOT NEW BUT IT'S BEEN
EXASPERATED BY THE PANDEMIC- THE
ECONOMIC LOSS TO OUR COUNTRY TO
CALIFORNIA'S IN THE BILL AND
BILLIONS AND THE NUMBER ONE WHO
LEFT THE LABOR FORCE BECAUSE OF
CODE BECAUSE OF CHILDCARE
DUTIES. IS ASTRONOMICAL AND SO
THIS IS REALLY A TARGETED
APPROACH INTO ADDRESSING THOSE
ISSUES AND CERTAINLY SUPPORTING
SMALL BUSINESSES WHICH IS A NEW
WAY OF APPROACHING THIS-
CONSIDERING THAT THERE'S THREE
POINT NINE SMALL BUSINESSES IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE REPRESENT-
HALF OR MORE OF THE PRIVATE
WORKFORCE HERE AT ARMS SUCH AS
ECONOMIC ENGINE- THE FACT THAT
THEY CAN NOT. AT ALL FOR TO
SUPPORT THEIR EMPLOYEES WITH
CHILDCARE- BECAUSE IT'S TOO
PROHIBITIVE FOR THEM TO BECAUSE
THERE'S SO MANY PRESSURES AND
BECAUSE CODE IS JUST A
HIGHLIGHTED THE FRAGILITY OF
THESE BUSINESSES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY IN SPECIALLY CALIFORNIA
TO- WE REALLY WANTED TO TARGET
THIS AND BE THOUGHTFUL ABOUT HOW
COULD WE INCENTIVIZE SMALL
BUSINESSES AND ALLOW THEM TO BE
SUPPORTIVE. OF THEIR WORKERS
MANY OF WHOM WORK NONTRADITIONALHOURS OR SHIFT WORK- AND AGAIN
THESE ARE THE ONES WHO MAY NOT
BE ABLE TO QUALIFY FOR
SUBSIDIZED CARE I CAN'T PAY FOR
IT ON THEIR OWN. AND WITH
CALIFORNIA BEING A NATIONAL
LEADER IN SUPPORTING WOMAN AND
PAID FAMILY LEAVE AND OTHER
POLICIES WE THINK THAT THIS FITS
WITH WITH WHAT CALIFORNIA IS
GOOD DOING WHICH IS SERVING AS A
NATIONAL MODEL FOR THE REST OF
THE COUNTRY. THANK YOU. I THANK
YOU. ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER CORK
. THEY ARE HAVING TO RAISE TWO
KIDS FORTUNATELY WITH ENOUGH
MONEY SO WE COULD AFFORD TO
NEIGHBORHOOD DAY CARE FROM FROM
MOMS I THINK THIS IS REALLY
IMPORTANT- I DON'T KNOW HOW FAR
IT'S GOING TO GET THE MAIN THING
WOULD BE GETTING THE MONEY IN
THE BUDGET- WE EITHER NEED TO
GET SOMETHING LIKE THIS. OR SOME
SORT OF CREDIT THAT WE CAN GIVE
TO PARENTS BUT THIS IS A CENTRAL
HI HAVE YOU HAD BUDGET
DISCUSSIONS. IT'S CERTAINLY
SOMETHING THAT WE ARE STILL AN
IN THE WORKS OF DISCUSSING AND
DEFINITELY AN OPTION BUT RIGHT
NOW WE THINK THAT DIRECT
PAYMENTS- I'M SORRY FOR DIRECT
K. CREDITS TO THE BUSINESSES IS
THE BEST WAY TO ENSURE THAT
MIDDLE CLASS FAMILIES ACTUALLY
GET THIS. ALL RIGHT WELL- POLVO
FOR IT HERE- THE MAIN THING WILL
BE GETTING MONEY IN THE BUDGET
TO FUND. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS ALL RIGHT OF I'D I
JUST I'M TRYING TO KIND OF- WRAP
MY MIND AROUND THE TAX CREDITS
ARE SO THE EMPLOYERS ARE GETTING
TAX CREDITS FOR THE PLATFORMS
ALSO RIGHT. IF YOU USE THAT IF
YOU USE THE PLATFORM THEN THAT
THAT THE EMPLOYER IS GOING TO
GET A TAX CREDIT FOR THAT. YEAH
OTHER FOR THE WITNESS YES IT
THAT IS ESSENTIALLY A MANAGER SO
THE EMPLOYER IS BENEFITING FROM
TAX RATE BECAUSE THEY'RE
SUBSIDIZING OFFERING THESE CARE
BENEFIT TALK INTO THE MICROPHONE
I'M SORRY FOR THE PLANS NAME I'M
SAYING IT INTO TO IT BECAUSE
YOU'RE BECAUSE WHAT I'VE NOTICED
WITH THE I MEAN WITH THE LEAD
THERE'S NOT A LONG LIST OF
SUPPORTERS EXCEPT FOR YOUR
COMPANY AND SO- AND YOU'RE
PROVIDING A PLATFORM SO I'M
ASSUMING THAT THE THERE'S A COST
TO THE PLATFORM AND THE
EMPLOYERS GETTING AT TAX CREDIT
FOR THAT. YES SO THE WAY THAT
THIS IS STRUCTURED AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL AND BE
COMPLEMENTARY STATE LEVEL
CREDITS THAT DO EXIST SO RIGHT
NOW. WHAT IS TERMED A QUALIFIED
EXPENDITURES THE FEDERAL LEVEL
IS CENTER BASED CARE FAMILY
CHILD CARE OR UTILIZING WHICH
TERMS- CHILD CARE RESOURCE
REFERRAL SERVICE THOSE ARE ALL
TERMS THAT COME OUT OF THE SEA
CDBG THE CHILD CARE COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT BLOCK GRANT FUNDING
SCHEMA- THOSE TERMS THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THAT'S A BLOCK GRANT
GOING TO THE STATES- IN SO UNDER
THAT SCENARIO IF THE EMPLOYER IS
CONTRACTING WITH FOR EXAMPLEA
BRICK AND MORTAR CHILD CARE
CENTER IN PAYING THEM FOR LET'S
SAY YOU KNOW THEY NEGOTIATE FOR
TEN SLOTS FOR THEIR TEN
EMPLOYEES KID- AND THEN THE
UTILIZED THAT SO THEY'RE WRITING
DOWN THE COST OF THEIR PAYING A
BRICK AND MORTAR SHOP. TO
PROVIDE THAT BENEFIT TO THEIR
EMPLOYEES AND SIMILARLY WITH THE
FAMILY CHILDCARE CENTER OR
SIMILARLY WITH A CHILD CARE
RESOURCE AND REFERRAL SO IN THIS
INSTANCE AND WHAT WE'RE
PROPOSING THE MODERNIZATION
PIECE IF YOU WILL IS TO EXPAND
IT TO INCLUDE IN HOMECARE AND
BACK UP CARE OPTIONS WHICH IS
WHAT PLATFORMS LIKE CARE .COM
OFFERS WELLS BUT WE ALSO HAVE
WITHIN OUR NETWORK CHILD CARE
CENTERS THAT WE CONTRACT WITH TO
HELP THE BACKUP CARE SPOTS AND
SO IT KIND OF RUNS THE GAMUT- IN
SO WE'RE NOT TRYING TO PROPOSE
ANYTHING THAT'S SPECIFICALLY
BENEFITING US MORE DIRECTLY THAN
THE CURRENT SCHEME IS ALREADY
DUE FOR THE WAY THAT THAT'S
CREDIT- INTERACTS AND HOW THE
HOW THE EMPLOYERS CAN CAN TAKE
THAT. AND I WOULD ALSO JUST SAY
WE'RE PROPOSING HERE FOR
CALIFORNIA THAT THIS DOESN'T
JUST INCLUDE CARE .COM SERVICES-
YOU KNOW OUR COMPETITORS WITH
BENEFIT FROM IT- ALSO INCLUDING.
CENTER BASED CARE. ON SITE CARE
FOR EMPLOYERS DECIDES TO PUT
CAPITAL EXPENSES INTO BUILDING
NOT. ON IT WOULD BE IN
CONFORMITY OR AT LEAST WE
ENVISION THAT IT WOULD BE IN
CONFORMITY MAY BE HAPPY TO
FURTHER DEFINE THAT DEFINITION
ONLY AND ALIGN THAT WITH THE
FEDERAL CREDIT- BUT WE'RE REALLY
JUST PROPOSING THAT YOU PUT. ALL
OPTIONS ON THE TABLE FOR
FAMILIES- ESPECIALLY IN
RECOGNITION. OF THE HYBRID
WORKFORCE ENVIRONMENT IN THE
CHANGING DYNAMICS. OF THEIR
NEEDS FOR CARAMEL. THANK YOU FOR
THAT AND IT IS FOR THE COURT
CLARIFIED DOES IT CREATES- A
CREDIT UNDER THE PERSONAL INCOME
TAX AND CORPORATE TAX SO. IT
WOULD ACTUALLY GO TO PERSON THE
REASON WHY PERSONAL INCOME TAXES
BECAUSE IT SOMETIMES YOU HAVE.
SMALL FAMILY PROVIDERS WHO ARE
SOLE PROPRIETORS OF THEIR CHILD
CARE CENTER- WITHIN THEIR OWN
HOME AND OR OBVIOUSLY CORPORATE
TAX ALSO WOULD ALSO APPLY TO
BUSINESSES WHO ARE INCORPORATED.
RIGHT OKAY. THANK YOU- WOULD YOU
LIKE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION WAS LIKE TO CLOSE.
YES AB TWENTY EIGHT OH THREE IS
A POWERFUL OPPORTUNITY SUPPORT
THE MISSING MIDDLE. AND TO
SUPPORT BUSINESSES THAT NEED TO
BE COMPETITIVE IN CALIFORNIA'S
IN RECRUITING CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE. CHILD CARE IS AN
ESSENTIAL SERVICE AND WE NEED TO
PROVIDE WORKING AND MIDDLE CLASS
PARENTS WITH ENOUGH SUPPORT IN
OPTIONS TO ENSURE THAT CHILD
CARE IS ACCESSIBLE. AND
AFFORDABLE FOR ALL I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE IF IT
COMES UP BEFORE YOU FOR A VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION AGAIN. THE
NEXT WE HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RIVAS WHO WILL BE PRESENTING FOR
MISTER GIPSON. ON THE AB.
EIGHTEEN SIXTY FOUR. WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RIVAS THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS- THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT-
AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY FOUR ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER MIKE GIPSON-
THIS BILL SEEKS TO INCENTIVIZE
SMALL BUSINESSES TO HIRE LOCALLY
. THE BILL INTENDS TO HELP OUR
COMMUNITIES HEAVIEST HIT BY THE
PANDEMIC BY INCREASING LOCAL JOB
OPPORTUNITIES ASSISTING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS IN RETAINING
CRITICAL REVENUE AND PROVIDING
THE SOLUTION TO ADDRESS ISSUES
RELATED TO HIGH COMMUTING.
SPECIFICALLY AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY
FOUR SIX TO CREATE A TAX CREDIT
FOR SMALL BUSINESSES THAT BRING
ON A FULL TIME NEWLY HIRED
EMPLOYEE WHO LIVES WITHIN A FIVE
MILE RADIUS OF THEIR PLACE OF
BUSINESS. THIS TAX CREDIT IS
TARGETED TOWARD SMALLER MOM AND
POP BUSINESSES WITH FORTY NINE
OR FEWER EMPLOYEES THIS IS A
CREDIT OF FOUR HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FOUR DOLLARS THAT SMALL
BUSINESSES CAN BENEFIT FROM PER
ELIGIBLE EMPLOYEE. THIS AMOUNT
<c.red>S EXACTLY IN LINE WITH PAYROLL</c>
TAX INCREASES RELATED TO
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE THE HOPE
IS THAT THIS CREDIT CAN OFFSET
SOME OF THOSE COSTS. SMALL
BUSINESSES NEED ALL OF THE HELP
THEY CAN GET ESPECIALLY AS A
RESULT OF COVERT NINETEEN. IT IS
WIDELY KNOWN THAT LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR HAVE BEEN
HIT THE HARDEST DURING THE
PANDEMIC. THESE ARE THE SAME
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE
HISTORICALLY STRUGGLED WITH JOB
SCARCITY DUE TO LIMITED
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES AND AS
A RESULT THESE COMMUNITIES ARE A
PART OF THE STATE'S COMMUTER
REGION'S STRUGGLING WITH HIGH
TRANSPORTATION COSTS AND
POLLUTION. REDUCING THE QUALITY
OF LIFE AND FURTHERING HEALTH
AND ECONOMIC DISPARITIES ALL OF
THESE ISSUES DECREASED THE HOPE
THE CALIFORNIA WILL MEET AT ZERO
IT'S ZERO EMISSIONS GOALS IN A
TIMELY MATTER. OUR COMMUNITIES
NEED INNOVATIVE WAYS TO ADDRESS
THESE ISSUES SIMPLY STATED WE
NEED TANGIBLE SOLUTIONS TO
PROVIDE JOB OPPORTUNITIES FOR
RESIDENTS IN OUR MOST
DISADVANTAGED AND UNDER RESOURCE
COMMUNITIES. THESE SOLUTIONS
INCLUDED. THE CREATION OF. ALL
OF THESE THESE SOLUTIONS
INCENTIVIZE AND HELP OUR LOCAL
BUSINESSES- TO EMPLOY- THESE
INDIVIDUALS SMALL BUSINESSES ARE
A CRITICAL PART OF THE AMERICAN
FABRIC THEY ARE THE KEY TO
BUILDING GENERATIONAL WEALTH. WE
NEED TO CONTINUE EMPOWERING ARE
MOM AND POPS AND AB EIGHTEEN
SIXTY FOUR SEEKS TO DO JUST THAT
. JOINING ME TODAY IN PERSON AS
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS RELATED TO
THIS BILL. I HAVE MY DS SALINAS
WITH THE LOS ANGELES AREA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND BIANCA
BLOM QUEST WITH THE SMALL
BUSINESS MAJORITY. GOOD
AFTERNOON LADIES AND THEN YOU'LL
HAVE TWO MINUTES EACH. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR IRWIN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS MARIA SALINAS I'M PRESIDENT
CEO OF THE LOS ANGELES AREA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE A
REPRESENTING THE LARGER- GREATER
LOS ANGELES AREA WE'RE SPANO A
PROUD SPONSOR OF AB EIGHTEEN
SIXTY FOUR. LOS ANGELES IS A
DYNAMIC REGION WITH A GLOBAL
ECONOMY THAT IS SIGNIFICANT AND
THIS ECONOMY IS POWERED BY THE
SMALL BUSINESSES THE SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT ARE BACKBONE OF
THE ECONOMY THEY ARE THE
INNOVATORS AND THE JOB CREATORS
IN LA COUNTY ALONE 93% OF
BUSINESSES HAVE LESS THAN TWENTY
EMPLOYEES AND 55% OF THOSE
BUSINESSES ARE WOMEN AND
MINORITY OWNED BUSINESSES AND
WHEN YOU THINK. OF THAT POWER OF
HOW THEY POWER AN INTERNATIONAL
ECONOMY IN LOS ANGELES IT IS
JUST REALLY SIGNIFICANT THAT WE
SIT HERE TODAY TO SUPPORT THIS-
THIS- BELT. SMALL BUSINESSES
CREATE EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES
AS A FORMER FORMER SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER MYSELF I KNOW
THAT CREATING JOBS AND GROWING
THOSE JOBS HAVE A POSITIVE
IMPACT ON LOCAL ECONOMIES ON
FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES WE ARE
INTER RELATED TODAY AS WE EMERGE
FROM THE PANDEMIC SMALL
BUSINESSES CAN USE EVERY HELP
THEY CAN GET TO GET BACK ON FIRM
FOOTING. AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY FOUR
IS ONE OF THOSE BILLS. RATES A
TAX CREDIT TO HELP INCENTIVIZE
LOCAL HIRE LOCAL HIRE CAN MAKE A
DIFFERENCE IN OUR NEIGHBORHOODS
WERE SMALL BUSINESSES THRIVE
ACROSS THE STATE. WHILE SOME
RELIEF HAS BEEN PROVIDED BY WAY
OF THE STATE AND FEDERAL
GOVERNMENTS SMALL BUSINESSES
CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE AND WE NEED
TO IDENTIFY MORE SOLUTIONS THAT
CAN OFFER THOSE KIND OF BENEFITS
TO THE SMALL BUSINESSES LIKE
HIRING FROM LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
ADDITIONAL PAYROLL TAXES YOU
KNOW WHILE THEY'RE NECESSARY
HAVE BURDEN THOSE MOM AND POP
SHOPS THAT ARE STILL LOOKING FOR
RELIEF WE AT THE CHAMBER WORK
WITH MANY SMALL BUSINESSES AND
WE KNOW THEY ARE STILL
STRUGGLING AND ARE LOOKING FOR
THOSE INNOVATIVE SOLUTIONS LIKE
LOCAL HIGHER. AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY
FOUR WILL BE THAT SOLUTION WE
AGREE THAT IT CAN MAKE A
DIFFERENCE NOT ONLY WITHIN A
SMALL BUSINESS. ORGANIZATION BUT
ALSO WITHIN COMMUNITY I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR A VOTE
ON AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY FOUR AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME TODAY. THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE SMALL BUSINESS
MAJORITY SUPPORTS AB EIGHTEEN
SIXTY FOUR BECAUSE THAT WILL
PROVIDE A COMPETITIVE ADVANTAGE
FOR SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS AND
CREATE QUALITY JOBS IN OUR
STATE. MY NAME IS BIANCA BLOM
QUESTION I'M POLICY DIRECTOR FOR
SMALL BUSINESS MAJORITY A
NATIONAL NONPROFIT WITH A
NETWORK OF EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND
DIVERSE BUSINESS OWNERS WORKING
TO BUILD THRIVING AND EQUITABLE
ECONOMIES. WE ALSO CONDUCT
EXTENSIVE RESEARCH THAT FOCUSES
ON THE SMALLEST BUSINESSES
FACING SYSTEMIC INEQUITIES.
SMALL BUSINESSES PROVIDE AN
ACCESS POINT FOR MANY TO BUILD
GENERATIONAL WEALTH NOT ONLY DO
THEY CONTRIBUTE A GREAT DEAL OF
TAX DOLLARS TO THEIR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THEY ALSO PROVIDE
LONG TERM BENEFITS. AND EMPLOY
APPROXIMATELY ONE IN THREE
CALIFORNIA WORKERS AN
OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF THE IS
BEING WOMEN AND PEOPLE OF COLOR.
INVESTING IN SMALL USINESS
OWNERS MEANS INVESTING IN A
DIVERSE WORK FORCE IN OUR POLL
PEOPLE OF COLOR MAKE UP AT LEAST
HALF OF THOSE ON STAFF FOR THE
MAJORITY OF BUSINESS OWNERS OF
COLOR. AND WOMEN EMPLOYED MANY
01:34:53.087 --